>> Tucker: THAT WAS 2007.
13 YEARS AGO.
IT WAS GOOD ADVICE.
WE SHOULD HAVE TAKEN IT.
DOUGLAS McGREGOR, AUTHOR AND
FREQUENT GUEST ON THE SHOW, HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> SURE.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD BE THE
REASON TO STAY IN IRAQ AT THIS
POINT?
>> I CAN'T THINK OF ANY, TO BE
PERFECTLY BLUNT WITH YOU.
NONE THAT ARE ANY GOOD.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO SYMPATHIZE
WITH THOSE ARABS IN IRAQ WHO
WOULD LIKE US TO STAY AS SOME
SORT OF COUNTERWEIGHT TO IRAN.
WE HAVE NO VITAL STRATEGIC
INTEREST THAT COMPELS US TO BE
THERE.
THE PRESIDENT IS VERY LUCKY.
THESE MISSILES, AS YOU POINTED
OUT, WERE TARGETED IN ADVANCE
AND WE WERE INFORMED IN ADVANCE
OF WHERE THEY WERE GOING TO
LAND, SO WE WERE ABLE TO
EVACUATE SOLDIERS, SAILORS,
AIRMEN AND MARINES HAVE HAVE NO
CASUALTIES.
THE PRESIDENT MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION NOT TO RESPOND.
HE NEEDS TO LIVE UP TO THE
PROMISES HE MADE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND PULL US OUT OF SYRIA
AND IRAQ.
THAT WAR IS OVER.
WE LOST IT.
IRAN IS A WINNER AT THE MOMENT.
IT WON'T BE A WINNER FOR VERY
LONG.
IRAN HAS TO COMPETE WITH THE
TURKS AND THE CITY OF ISLAMISTS
FOR THE CITY OF IRAQ.
OUR INTERESTS BEGIN ALONG A LINE
THAT RUNS ACROSS THE TOP OF
ISRAEL, JORDAN, SAUDI ARABIA,
AROUND KUWAIT AND DOWN TO THE
MIDDLE OF THE PERSIAN GULF.
THAT'S WHERE OUR INTERESTS --
>> Tucker: ON TO THE GULF.
OF COURSE.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT IF WE WANT
TO IMPEDE THE GROWTH OF IRAN'S
INFLUENCE IN THE REGION, HAND
THEM IRAQ AND WISH THEM LUCK.
IN THE SAME WAY THAT THE SOVIETS
INVADE
INVAING AFGHANISTAN
PRECIPITATED THE END OF THE
SOVIET EMPIRE.
>> HE COVETS NORTHERN IRAQ.
HE WOULD LIKE TO CONTROL ALL OF
SYRIA.
HE IS SENDING TROOPS INTO LIBYA
AND TUNISIA.
HE IS THE NEW PROBLEM FOR US.
NOT IRAN.
IRAN REALLY IS ON THE ROPES.
ITS POPULATION IS SICK TO DEATH
OF THE WARS BEING FOUGHT IN IRAQ
AND SYRIA BY PROXY FORCES AND BY
IRANIANS.
THEY'VE TAKEN THOUSANDS OF
CASUALTIES.
MR. SOLEIMANI WAS POPULAR WITH
MANY, BUT VERY UNPOPULAR WITH
OTHERS.
ESPECIALLY THE PEOPLE THAT LOST
SONS FIGHTING IN THOSE
COUNTRIES.
LET'S GET OUT, LEAVE IT ALONE,
LET THE PEOPLE THERE SORT IT
OUT.
AND THEY WILL.
IRAN'S NOT GOING TO BE POPULAR
FOR VERY LONG IN IRAQ.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANY HOPE
THAT THAT HAPPENS?
>> WELL, THE PRESIDENT CAN DO
IT.
HE HAS A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY
NOW.
HE HAS A NEW POINT OF DEPARTURE.
HE CAN TAKE THE CLEAN SHEET AND
PUT IT ON THE TABLE AND HE CAN
SIT WITH THE IRANIANS AND SAY,
LOOK, WHAT ARE YOUR INTERESTS,
TELL US, WE'LL TELL YOU WHAT
OURS ARE.
HE CAN DRAW THAT LINE THAT I
MENTIONED.
THAT CAN BECOME THE TRUMP LINE.
THAT'S HOW GREAT POWERS SORT
THINGS OUT.
BUT THERE'S NO SUPPORT IN THIS
COUNTRY TO STAY IN IRAQ AND
SYRIA.
THERE IS NO SUPPORT IN THE
UNITED STATES FOR A WAR OVER
THERE.
HE KNOWS THAT.
SO WE HAVE TWO GROUPS OF PEOPLE
THAT KNOW SOMETHING.
THE LEADERSHIP IN TEHRAN KNOWS
IT DOESN'T WANT A WAR WITH US.
WE KNOW WE DON'T WANT A WAR WITH
THEM.
WHAT A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO